no have we got a treat for you now let
me introduce you to lend McCluskey's
little red book well actually maybe more
burnt sienna in which the boss of one of
Britain's biggest trade unions reflects
in his personal journey from the
Liverpool docks to well arguably the
most powerful man in the labour party
after the leader and the general
secretary of unite even Union led
McCluskey joins us now mr. McClosky very
good morning to you good morning meal um
there was a wonderful court I was going
through the introduction to your book
last night in fact err mr. McCluskey and
it says this I sincerely hope that by
the time why you should be a trade
unionist reaches bookshops that this
nation has achieved a last incredible
settlement one that heals our divisions
and gives hopes of a fairer future for
all the people of this country now that
was written in November what went wrong
in December
well obviously labour suffered a major
major defeat primarily as far as I'm
concerned because of brexit sir the more
we slid in to be perceiving perceived as
a romaine party the more the
consequences were going to be felt in
our heart once many of those seats that
we've lost virtually all of them voted
leave and there was a feeling of
betrayal the Labour Party had betrayed
them and we suffered the consequence of
us were telling the leadership that's
and we've been telling them that for
many many months but that's the position
and we have to just ourselves down
choose a new leader and move on to win
back the trust of those heartlands /
indeed the rest of the nations as well
and indeed unite has come out for
Rebecca long Bailey and Richard Bergen
and there are those who see this as as
almost continuity Corbin and given the
fact that two general elections have
been lost in that vein what is the
rationale for those choices well I don't
believe it's fair on Becky to talk in
terms of continuity Corbin she's her own
individual people we'll see she's strong
courageous brave she's certainly capable
and she
able to take forward hair vision it will
be hair vision she believes in the
radical nature of Labour's policies and
it's up to her now indeed whoever
becomes leader the challenge is to take
those arguments back out to the nation
you say that we've lost two elections of
course - not half years ago in 2017
labour came within touching distance of
power with that you went back from that
point though it strikes me that the part
of the problem the Labour Party has at
the moment is that 2017 is often talked
about 2019 really I mean the
Conservatives outperformed labour by
double digits amongst manual workers and
households that are in jointly less than
than 20,000 yeah I think as I've just
said that was virtually solely down to
breakfast Labour's policies and there
are those on the right of the party and
indeed in the media who were trying to
suggest that it was the policies Corbyn
policies were rejected overwhelmingly by
the population including the men said
surely mr. McClosky oriented Corbyn the
man I mean you said that Rebecca long it
was like the brains and the brilliance
to take on Boris Johnson and I love the
alliteration but it does also suggest
that Jeremy Corbyn didn't have the
brains and the brilliance no I think the
reality and I have to keep repeating
this then you'll have to forgive me
years ago Jeremy Corbett Jeremy Cobham
was loved what happened in the last two
years breakfasts and Labor's inability
to effectively stay with their 2017
manifesto position of respecting the
2016 referendum and arguing to take
labour and the country out of Europe or
on a deal that protects jobs and
investment that got lost in the two
years and that affected how people
perceive Jeremy as as a leader and we
paid the consequences for that but the
policies that Labour stood for and the
policies a number of them Rebecca long
Bailey supports are extremely popular
amongst the election now brexit is gone
obviously we'll still have lots of
between now and the end of the year as
this government tries to cut appropriate
trade deals and I wish to look on that
although I have my severe concerns about
what might happen but praxis is gone by
the time the next election comes about
five years or if it's earlier than that
the issues will then be about what
effect ordinary working people and
that's when Li was radical alternative
to the type of society that we have will
kick in we run out of time
we are going to run out of time but the
anti-semitism allegations of
anti-semitism within the labor movement
were clearly also part of the reason
that labor didn't perform to some
people's expectations which does rather
make the probably the union's nomination
the union support for Richard Birkin
slightly strange of West retn calling
for him and in fact Don Butler to be
ruled out of the deputy leadership
contest because they refused to sign up
to the Board of Deputies closet Board of
Deputies recommendations on
anti-semitism well that's not a nonsense
of course we're stressing would say that
wouldn't you think the fact of the
matter is that both dawn and Board of
Deputies would say as well
Bogg dawn and Richard have made it clear
that they believe that there is a need
for more debates and discussion about a
couple of the points that are in the
border deputies temple edgiest most of
them are fine or a couple of them need
fair their consideration I think that's
perfectly legitimate sand for people to
call for them to be kicked out of the
races or to nonces another line and from
your book you can tell them over a she's
reader mr. McCluskey
but another line from your book that
lactated me we should be more prepared
to challenge the law rather than
accepting that that certain actions are
illegal which aspects of the law is it
that you're referring to there and are
you yourself personally willing to leads
illegal strikes
well of course the truth of the matter
is the type of legislation that has been
introduced by consecutive Tory
governments is to try to minimize the
effect of trade unions and all those I'm
looking for also I've been looking for
for a while is for British workers to be
treated as fairly as all the work is in
the rest of Europe we were the ones this
nation who defeated fascism and and gave
Europe all of the freedoms that they
currently have I was it possible that
German workers and it's how do you work
as a French and Dutch and all the rest
be specific be specific which laws which
laws would you challenge the laws about
the thresholds if you've got in a
situation where a thresholds are not met
but a work is still wish to take
industrial action then they should be
allowed to do that the reality is that I
said to David Cameron I've said to
Theresa May and I'll say it abhorrest
Johnson allow us to have workplace
branch meetings and votes where plates
votes and you can have as many as many
thresholds as you like but the postal
thresholds are notorious for turning out
low low tenants and that is just wrong
and undemocratic and if they gave us
proper work place ballots which of
course both Boris and Teresa may have
then we would have a situation whereby
thresholds were perfectly legitimate to
accept but trying to kind of force
workers with some technicality workers
who have a grievance that they cannot
take industrial action it's plain wrong
to me and I think we should be prepared
to stand up and stand
shoulder-to-shoulder with our members
when McCroskey always good to see thanks
for joining us thank you